if an app updates in the background but
no one opens it to find out did it
really happen
notifications started off as a
convenient way to notify users of
background updates but they've grown to
become a powerful standardized shortcut
to interact directly with apps in a
lightweight way starting in jellybean it
was possible to expand notifications
making them larger and containing more
information that also introduced the
concept of the rich notification which
is able to include actions like these to
be performed on the data included within
the notification the speeds up
interaction and helps users streamline
their notification triage experience as
a standardized UI designed specifically
for conveying timely information in
limited screen space notifications are
the obvious mechanism to use when
Android expanded into wearables with
Android wear suddenly those rich
notifications that you designed for
phones and tablets make your app
wearable compatible for free don't
overdo it though there's a fine line
between useful and spammy and it's only
a couple of clicks for a user to disable
your apps notifications permanently so
check out the instructor notes below for
links to the design guide on creating
good notifications